CRAIG MCLUCKIE:
The last few months
have been pretty exciting
from a containers perspective.
I don't know if everyone's
as excited about containers
as I am.
[AUDIENCE CHEERS]
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Awesome.
But we've actually seen a lot
of interesting developments
in this space.
The first, and possibly
the most noteworthy,
has been Docker, which is a
very popular Linux application
container stack going
into production,
so being production
ready, which is great.
And at Google, we've
been working hard
to make the Google Cloud
Platform the best place
to run containers.
And we've had two releases.
One, we introduced container
optimized virtual machines
in May.
And we followed that up
recently, just a couple weeks
ago, introducing an open source
scheduler called Kubernetes.
And my name's Craig.
I'm a product guy.
And I'm going to take a
few minutes to talk you
through Linux
application containers.
Some of the stuff the people
that were cheering probably
already know.
But hopefully
it'll give everyone
a better sense of
what they mean.
And I'll take some
time to explain
what they mean to Google,
like how Linux application
containers have really
helped us at Google,
and where the intersection
of these things is going.
And then, I'll hand off to
my colleague Brendan, who's
going to go through in a
lot more technical detail
around the stuff that we've
actually put into the market
right now that you can
get your hands on and use.
So let's kick this off and say,
what is a Linux application
container?
What does it mean to people?
At the heart, a Linux
application container
is a very simple way to package
up all of your application
pieces into a single
hermetically sealed unit
that you can then deploy
into an environment and run.
And it has a lot of really
favorable properties
that we'll go through in detail.
And if you actually
step back and just
think about what it
means, it's really
raising the abstraction level.
So historically, the
abstraction level
that most developers
have worked with
has been at the virtual machine
level, the hardware level.
And with Docker
virtual machines,
you have this idealized
hardware that you
can run multiple instances on.
But it pulls thought
a lot of other goop.
With Docker and with Linux
application containers,
we've actually moved the
abstraction up so that you now
have-- instead of having an
idealized hardware stack,
you actually have an
idealized operating system.
That's a very powerful metaphor.
So that's great-- woo hoo.
Increased abstraction level--
everyone loves abstraction.
What does it mean to
me as a developer?
I'm not actually
really a developer.
But if I were , what
would that mean?
Why do you care, right?
And the reason our developers
care, and the reason
I care where I'm actually
playing a developer,
is this ability to create a
static, hermetically sealed
unit radically simplifies
the process of deployment.
It creates a much more
predictable and isolated
framework to package up
your application bits, all
of its user LAN dependencies,
and get it out there
into this idealized
Linux environment.
It means that your
application is now
isolated from other applications
from a resource perspective.
It's dependencies
are all sealed in.
And it radically reduces
the amount of stress
that you experience when
you're deploying applications
or updating those applications.
And a lot of customers I speak
to, this is the first epiphany.
They say, wow, this has
really changed the game.
This fundamentally redefines the
way we think about operations.
And so that's very exciting.
The next thing that
people encounter
is this idea of portability.
OK, this is great.
I have this idealized
operating system.
It means I can
produce, effectively,
an executable that
runs here or there.
It runs in my local development
machine in a very lightweight
place that I've just set
up with Vagrant or whatever
technologies.
And I can take that same package
and have a very high degree
of confidence that
it's going to work
in my bulletproof enterprise
grade Red Hat environment,
or whatever environment
that I'm running in, right?
And so this idea of
portability is huge.
But it's not just
about portability
between your development,
testing, and production
environments, which
might be different.
It also offers the
idea of portability
between cloud environments.
And at Google, we're very
proud of Google Compute Engine.
We've put a lot
of time and effort
into making it an
incredibly robust framework
for running workloads.
But we want our customers to
pick it because it's awesome.
We don't want to lock them in.
And with these
container technologies,
it's the first time that
customers have really
had an opportunity to
package up their application
in a framework that's portable,
that can run in Google Compute
Engine, or in another
cloud, or in their sort
of personal cloud,
their private cloud.
And these container formats
offer a very high level
of portability, which is great.
And then finally, when I talk
to customers, the penny's kind
of dropping around,
wow, not only can I
think about my application
as being sort of hermetically
sealed, but I can actually
start to decouple it, take
these application pieces
and put them together
into loosely
coupled systems that
are much more easy to manage
and are much less intrinsically
bound together.
So instead of having
all of these pieces
in the soup of an operating
system environment,
I can tease them apart and
control them separately.
And I can mix in stuff.
I can mix in pieces that are
provided by the open source
community.
And I'm hoping that
we'll very soon start
to see ISVs producing
commercial software that
can be mixed in the same way.
Microservices is very powerful.
And all that's great.
And it's really catching on.
We're seeing a lot hype and a
lot of excitement around this.
Now, it turns out containers
have existed for a while.
And we've been using them in
Google for a very long time.
And we've actually approached
it from a slightly different
angle.
We get a lot of those benefits.
And we've really
benefited from them.
But there's a couple
of other things
that working in this container
in optimized environments
brings.
When you're doing
hyper-scale deployments
like we are, whether
it's search or Gmail,
efficiency is really
important, being
able to get every ounce out of
your underlying infrastructure.
And because we have very high
levels of resource isolation,
we're able to pack
things much more densely
and use very high level
algorithms to do that.
If you're doing
hyper-scale deployments,
predictability of
deployment is critical.
If you're deploying
something that
is as complicated
as the things we do,
having to worry about mapping
a specific application
to a specific piece of
hardware just doesn't work.
It doesn't scale.
And then, the quality
of service is huge.
A scaling event for
us doesn't involve
provisioning a virtual machine.
We already have a massive fleet.
It simply involves taking
a very lightweight thing
and dropping it into
another environment.
And the other thing is it
makes our developers better.
We have much higher levels
of introspectibility.
And so they're able
to actually get
a much better sense of what's
going on in their code.
They can understand what
resources they're using.
They can understand
what contention
they're experiencing.
And they're able to use
that to feed that back
and actually produce
more efficient code.
So at Google, we do start over
2 billion containers a week.
That's a lot of
containers, right?
That's 3,000 a second.
So when I say everything
runs in containers,
I mean everything
runs in containers.
And if you think
about that, I've
been talking for
seven minutes now.
So since I started talking,
we launched about 1.2 million
containers.
That's a lot of containers.
And the thing I'm
really excited about
is that thinking about
where we're going,
we've seen the ecosystem
rally around this efficient,
this portable,
decoupled framework.
Inside Google, we've created an
incredibly efficient framework
that's actively managing
your systems where
you as a developer at Google
aren't running something.
You're running code.
And you're handing it
off to these systems that
run it on your behalf.
And they do it far better
than you could possibly do it.
Because they're
constantly watching.
It's like a modern flight
control system in an airplane.
It's taking a lot of signals
and making very intelligent
decisions about what
to tune and what
to adjust to make the overall
system perform better.
And so we get efficiency.
And we can bring that
efficiency to our engineers
and radically drive down
the cost of operations.
We get performance like we
do with App Engine, which
is effectively a container-based
solution where a scaling
event happens in milliseconds
instead of tens of seconds,
which is what you see
with Compute Engine,
or minutes that you might see
with other cloud providers'
virtual machines.
Continuous integration
is really easy.
You can build something.
You can roll it
out a little bit.
If things don't work out, you
can roll it back very easily.
And then, overall it's a
much more robust system.
So we're extremely excited
about these technologies.
And I'm very
pleased to hand over
to Brendan, who's a
developer on our team
who's headed up a lot of these
initiatives to tell you more.
BRENDAN BURNS: Great.
So I'm really happy to give
you a guided tour of both
how we build cluster
management inside of Google
and how we're bringing
that knowledge to the cloud
platform.
As a bit of context, I worked
in this search infrastructure.
I worked in search
infrastructure for about four
years before I came
to the Google Cloud,
where I got to use this cluster
management to provide the back
ends that provide search for
Google+ and for recent events
in products like Google News.
And basically
anything that you see
in Google that is under
about 12 hours old
is coming out of software
that I or my teams wrote.
And so I'm particularly
excited to be
able to take some
of the systems that
enabled us to build
those scale systems
and make them available to
customers of the Google Cloud
Platform.
So if we take a look here, this
is a basic high level overview
of the Google cluster
management stack.
It's really split
into two pieces.
And I'm going to deal with each
of those pieces individually.
At the bottom, we have a node
container manager and a managed
base OS.
This is basically the
piece of software,
or the multiple
pieces of software,
that are distributed onto every
single machine in a Google data
center.
So every single machine in the
data center is homogeneous.
Every single machine is
running exactly the same set
of base infrastructure
that allows
it to execute
arbitrary containers.
Now on top of that,
the software that
runs Google Search or Gmail
or anything else that you use,
Docs or anything
else, runs inside
of a scheduled container.
Now, that container didn't
end up on that machine
because a developer
said, oh, I want
to put this on this specific
machine on this specific rack.
It ended up on that machine
because the developer said
to the cluster scheduler,
the master for the cluster,
I have this amount of work.
I would like to run 10
copies, 10 replicas,
of this piece of software.
It needs three cores,
and 10 gigs of memory,
and a little bit of disk.
Find me a place where
I can exist happily.
And the cluster
scheduler takes care
of things like figuring
out that it should
do spreading across
multiple machines
in order to avoid a
single point of failure.
It does things like
resource isolation.
So it understands
that I only have
this number of cores
on this machine.
There isn't enough
free cores there
for me to be able to
schedule your job there.
And it does all of
this on my behalf.
And so I can have this
declarative, abstract, high
level concept of a
piece of software
and a set of resources, and the
scheduler can make that happen.
All right, so for the
next 15 or 20 minutes,
I'm going to sort of step
you through how we're
bringing these concepts out and
making them available to people
inside of the Google
Cloud Platform.
And I'm going to start
by talking about the Node
Container Manager
if it switches.
All right, so the
Node Container Manager
is a system for
the cloud platform
at least that we released
in the middle of May.
And basically, it's a container
optimized virtual machine.
It's just a single
virtual machine image
that has been built with
software that makes it really,
really easy to run a
container on that VM.
We've standardized a
declarative container manifest,
which is a declarative statement
that basically specifies
the software that you would
like to run on this machine.
And it also does health
monitoring and some reliability
to ensure that if you
ask for something--
and one of the reasons
why we're really
interested in declarative
representations
is that the statement says,
I would like this thing
to be running.
It doesn't say,
please run this thing.
It says, I would like
this thing to be running.
And that means that the
responsibility for making sure
that that container continues
to run through failures,
through other problems that
might cause it to stop,
has been handed over to Google.
You no longer have
to worry about,
is this process
actually up and running?
The infrastructure
on the container VM
takes care of making
sure that that's true.
So we're going to take a
little bit of a deeper dive
into this container managed VM.
And we start with
basically looking
at a very simple example
of how you might create
one of these using
Google Compute Engine.
There's a large
amount of text there.
But basically what
it is doing is
it's creating a virtual machine
in the US central one zone.
It's an F1 micro, one
of our small instances.
It's using the
container VM image.
And it's setting a
metadata key from a file.
And that file is
the containers.yaml
that contains the actual
declarative specification
of what it is that
we would like to run.
Now, that containers.yaml
here is a very simple
stripped down representation
of all of the things
you could express.
And we'll go into
a little bit more
of the details in
the next few slides.
But what this is
basically saying is,
I would like to run
a single container.
I'm going to call
it dub, dub, dub.
It's going to run engine x.
That's the software that I
want you to run inside of it.
It's a sort of light weight,
high performance web server.
And I want to expose a port.
In this particular
case, it's going
to be the HTTP
port that's mapping
a port inside the
container on port 80
to the external 8080 container.
So that means that
when I create this VM,
it's not just booting
a virtual machine.
It's actually installing
this container.
It's starting it up and running.
And by the time this container
optimized VM is done,
you have a reliable
web server running
on port 8080 that can
start serving your traffic.
And if for some reason, either
due to a programming error
or to someone accidentally
killing that process on the VM,
the process dies and
the container dies,
it will be
automatically restarted.
And so you can be
assured that your web
server will continue
to function.
So in some cases,
we actually may
want to have more
than a single port.
Web servers often serve both
HTTP traffic and HTTPS traffic.
So here's an example expanding
on the previous declarative
specification.
Now we're adding a
second HTTPS port.
In this case, we're not
actually remapping the port.
We are simply keeping the port
443, the standard HTTPS port.
So we have the ability to have
essentially arbitrary network
ports.
And again, Craig mentioned
that introspection
is a big part of why
we like containers.
And ports are a
great example of why
this introspection is valuable.
So I can actually walk
up to this VM now,
and rather than just treating
it as a black box operating
system where in order to
understand what software
is running on it I
might need to run
an invasive tool like a
port scan or anything else
like that, in our UI, we can
actually walk up to this VM
and see, aha, they're
running a web server.
They're running an HTTPS server.
Maybe we'll add some links
that allow you to just
drive directly to that as part
of what the container VM looks
like.
So having this extra metadata,
this extra information
about the kinds of applications
that you're running on a VM,
actually enables the Google
Cloud Platform to provide
a better, richer experience
that actually gives you
deeper insight
than just, oh, hey,
we see that there's a
virtual machine running here.
So that sort of gives
you a brief example.
I wanted to step into a slightly
more complicated example of one
of these declarative manifests.
This is a pattern that we
see emerging a lot internally
inside of Google
and that we think
we see also happening in
the exterior world, which
is we actually want-- and this
idea is the notion that we have
containers that actually work
really symbiotically together.
They are containers who, in
the case of this example,
we may have a web search front
end that actually answers
your queries, the thing that
actually receives the request
and gives you back the
documents that match.
And it has a symbiotic
data loader container
that is always looking
out into the network,
finding new data shards
as new documents.
I mentioned I
worked in freshness.
As new documents
are made available,
new shards are built.
The data loader is responsible
for taking those things off
of the network, bringing
them onto local disks
so that those search engines can
actually serve those files out
to user requests.
Now, these containers have
very, very different resource
requirements and very,
very different quality
of service guarantees.
Obviously, we want the
searches that people
do to be as fast as possible.
And so we want to ensure that
the web search container has
high quality of service,
very, very low latency.
The data loader,
on the other hand,
is a background
batch processing job.
It's responsible for keeping
the server up to date.
And that's a very
important function.
But if it gets delayed
for a few seconds
while we're in the midst of
handling a burst of queries,
that's OK.
And so having these things
in two different containers
with two different resource
isolation boundaries
allows us to apply different
levels of quality of service
to the two different
containers and have
a really responsive user
experience that may actually
steal some resources from the
data loader when necessary.
The way that these two
containers communicate
is through a shared volume.
So you can see at the
very bottom there,
we have this volume
that's named Data Shard.
This volume in
the container spec
basically means that we will
create a shared directory that
is mounted into each
of these containers
where the shards are going
to be living so that the data
loader can copy the files
into that directory,
the web search software can read
from that directory, and load
in new data to serve searches.
So it's a shared object,
a shared piece of storage,
that both containers
can see and can use.
And yet, the two containers are
still isolated from each other.
Because they cannot see any of
the rest of the configuration
files, or the
application binaries,
or anything else that might
be inside the container.
So you only share what
is necessary to achieve
the symbiotic relationship.
You don't have these two
things in the same place
where they might
accidentally clobber
each other or anything
else like that.
So this is an example of how
you might build a relatively
sophisticated single
node application on top
of the Google container VM.
Oh, I think I hit
the Back button.
All right, so I
wanted to give you
a little bit of an
illustration of what's
actually happening on that VM.
On the left hand side?
Yes, the left hand side, you see
the stuff that Google provides.
This is the operating
system, obviously,
the monitoring and
logging agents.
The Docker daemon is
installed as well.
Tools like SSHD
or the init system
are all part of the
sort of software stack
that Google is providing as part
of the container managed VM.
In the user experience
side, well, we're
going to provide you with
a container environment.
This involves things
that you may pass in
like environment variables, the
parts that you want to open.
And then of course, your
code is going to actually
be running inside that
container environment as well.
So this is how we've really
taken a lot of the concerns
about running a
piece of software.
We've offloaded it onto
the Google managed VM.
And we have made
your code the thing
that you really
focus on running.
All right, so that gives you an
illustration of the node level
single machine management.
But really, if that was the
place that Google stopped,
we wouldn't have to have
these giant data centers that
are full of all kinds
of different machines.
The really interesting
thing that happens
is, well suddenly, what if I
have thousands of machines,
and I need to be
able to say, well
I have this set of
containers, could you
just make them run somewhere?
And so the job of
the cluster scheduler
is to absorb a set
of resources, make
it available to the user as
an abstract compute substrate,
an abstract pool of
compute that's available,
and then schedule work out into
that large pool of resources.
And so this system
has been developed
over a number of
years at Google as we
needed to push
utilization, as we needed
to improve the
developer experience.
And so about two weeks ago,
we announced a project,
an open source project
called Kubernetes.
It's ancient Greek for
pilot or helmsman of a ship.
And it's an open
source cluster manager
that tries to build
on some of the ideas
and patterns and paradigms
that we've developed
over 10 years of managing
containers at Google
and make those ideas available
out into the community.
Now at the same
time, we understand
that the containers that
people are using right now
are not necessarily the
containers that we've
used internally
inside of Google.
And so we really wanted
this open source project
to not just sort of be a
data dump or a knowledge
dump of the stuff
that we've learned,
but actually an
opportunity to explore
and expand and learn
with the community.
So I'm going to spend
the rest of the talk
basically stepping you
through Kubernetes,
giving you some examples,
and finally doing
a demo of the system.
All right, so Kubernetes
provides that scheduler layer.
It provides the master
scheduler binary.
It provides a set of machines
that are all identical.
They're running that container
node piece, the container
manager, on each
individual machine.
And it provides this
unified substrate
that you can schedule work
into without really caring
what machine it lands on.
So for example, I may have a
pod like that I was talking
about before where I have a web
server and a symbiotic task,
which is its log roller, right?
We can't let our log files
accumulate and accumulate
and accumulate.
We eventually will
run out of disk.
We need a log
roller that's going
to be responsible
for truncating a log,
shipping it off to a
system like BigQuery
or a more persistent cold
storage like Google Cloud
Storage.
So these are
symbiotic containers
that work well together.
The web server, obviously low
latency, serves user traffic.
The log roller batched
background kind of task.
It's responsible for
sort of maintaining
the health of the container--
again, sharing resources
through a shared data volume.
Now I, as a developer, define
that declarative representation
of, here's my web
server container,
here's my log roller container.
And I go to the
master, and I say, hey,
this is what I'd
like you to run.
And the master is the
thing that's actually
responsible for saying,
aha, I have this container
VM over here.
It's available.
I'll put the work
on there, all right?
And so if this was all you
were doing, if you only
wanted to run a single
task, or a few tasks,
this might be where you stopped.
And indeed, this
is where you could
stop if you wanted
to with Kubernetes.
You can simply use it as
a way to schedule work out
onto a cluster of
virtual machines.
But what we've
found internally is
that once you start
scheduling jobs,
and once you make it really,
really easy for users
to schedule work out into
their own personal cloud,
people start scheduling
a lot of pods, all right?
They start scheduling--
if you think of Git,
and in my traditional
Git client,
I have 10, maybe 15 branches.
I can deploy each
one of those branches
as a hermetically sealed
container running out
in my cluster.
And so pretty soon, I do that.
And I have lots of containers
running all over the place.
And it becomes very, very
hard to understand the system
and to reason about the system.
That one list of
containers that contained
four pretty containers
now contains hundreds.
It scrolls off the
bottom of a page,
and I need a way of
organizing this information.
And the way that we do
this inside of Kubernetes
is the notion of a label.
All right, so a label is
basically just a query
that you can execute across
a set of containers that
is keyed off of properties
of those container
key value pairs that are
properties of those containers.
So you can think
of this as being
sort of like a selector in
a UX framework like jQuery
or any number of other
kinds of querying usages.
So for example here, I might
have a label query that says,
I would like to
select everything
whose role is front end.
And you can see in
green now, I have
selected all of the front end
jobs that are running inside
of my Kubernetes cluster.
Well, this is only
sort of useful.
Because indeed, some
of those front ends
might be development front ends.
Some of those front ends might
be my neighbor's front ends.
I actually maybe don't
care about a lot of them.
And so label queries
can be conjunctive.
And so I can expand
on this label query
and say, OK, actually I'd
like the labels of the role
is front end and the
stage is production.
And you can see now all
of the front ends that
have dotted lines around them
have dropped away, right?
I put dotted lines
around them to illustrate
where they had been
in the previous query.
And the only front
ends that are left now
are the front ends that match
both the role being front end
and the stage being production.
And so now I have a
really elegant way
that I can slice through.
I can say, role is development
cluster, user is Brendan.
I can slice through
all of the things
that I've scheduled
out onto these machines
and find exactly the kind of
thing that I'm looking for.
And again, one thing
that's important to realize
is that I've stopped
viewing all of my containers
as things that are on particular
machines or things that
are running in any
particular place.
I've really started
to think of my cluster
as simply being this one giant
resource that a bunch of things
are running on.
And I stop really
having to worry or care
about specific locations.
And that's a pretty
powerful abstraction.
All right, but label
queries are nice for you
UX and for looking at things.
But they're really nice
when you start using them
as building blocks
for other services.
So one of the very
first things that you
want to do once you have
a single pod, a single set
of containers that work well,
is you want to scale it out.
This is where you've
stopped doing development,
and now you're moving towards
a production or a beta system.
You say, you know what?
That's the thing.
I want to cut out
10 copies of that.
I want to have a cookie cutter,
and I want a bunch of copies.
And we can use labels as
a way of organizing this
with the notion that we
call a replica controller.
And so a replica
controller basically
is the combination of a label
query for identifying what
containers you want to run, a
template, the cookie cutter,
if you will, for describing
the thing that you would like
to cut out, and a
number, which indicates
how many of that
thing you would like.
And so for example here, in
this declarative configuration
of this replica controller,
I have four replicas.
The template is
elided for space.
And then, I have a
label query that says,
and the role is front end
and the stage is production.
And the reason that the
label query is important
is because this object that is
responsible for the replication
is actually an active object.
It's a live reconciler
that is part of the system.
It's not an imperative
sort of execution of,
oh, I'm going to go
and-- it's not a for loop
that's going to go and create
four of these controllers.
It's an active
object in the system.
It's one of these
flight controllers
that Craig was
referring to that's
responsible for ensuring that
there are four of these things
always.
And so you can think of it
as constantly running a loop.
And the loop says,
execute label query.
OK, how many containers
did I get back?
Ah, I only got three back.
It says that I should have four.
Let me create a container.
OK, now I'll cycle again,
do the label query again.
Now I have four.
Great, I have four.
I won't take any action.
Do the label query again--
wait a minute, I have five.
How did that happen?
Kill one of those containers.
Ah, now I'm back to four.
So this is a live object
that lives in the system.
It means that the
system is self-healing.
It means that adding properties
like dynamic resizing,
as we'll see in the demo
later, becomes very, very easy
and very natural for the system.
This notion of a reconciler and
of an active controller inside
of a cluster manager is a
very, very important concept
that's core to a lot of
what we do at Google.
So the second thing that
we introduced that lives
on top of that label query
is the notion of a service.
Oh, excuse me.
I'm going to step
through my slides.
I spoke over my slides-- go
to one, go back to three.
All right, now we go back
to a service, excuse me.
So the notion of a service
says, well, you know,
it's great that I have this
replicated set of things.
But any real application, any
real application that I build,
needs to be linked
together, right?
I don't just have front ends.
I have front ends and back ends.
Maybe I have front ends and
back ends and middleware.
But if I have this replication
controller that is dynamically
resizing things, I don't want to
have to reconfigure everything.
If I take the set of back
ends from two to six,
I don't want to then
have to reconfigure
my front ends to understand
that there are six back end
servers now where
there used to be two.
And so the service
abstraction allows
you to have a named load
balancer that automatically
balances load across a label
query, a set of containers.
And it provides a
single network endpoint
that your front
ends can talk to.
And this all happens
automatically inside
of the Kubernetes system.
You declare a declarative
representation
of the service like
this-- back end service.
I want it to run on port 9000.
Here's the label query.
And Kubernetes for you
creates this service endpoint
on every single host
machine in the cluster
so that on any machine,
if you access port 9000,
and you open a
connection, you're
going to be transparently
load balanced
to one of the containers
that match this label
query, all right?
Again, the organization
of these containers
means that I can build up
these abstractions where I just
don't have to care about the
details of my system in places
where I don't need to.
All right, so with
that in mind, I
wanted to give you a brief demo
of the system in operation.
I'll try not to trip.
All right, so I'll jump
out of the web browser
and into my demo over here.
OK, is that visible?
Reasonably visible.
All right, so you may recognize
the fellow looking out at you.
I have here four containers.
This is replication controller
running four containers.
They're simple image servers.
They're serving out
a very simple image.
You can see this is
the container ID.
So the container ID is
different for each one.
And this is the IP address that
they happen to be running on.
And so the very first thing
I wanted to demonstrate
is some of the
self-healing properties.
And so I'm going
to go over here,
and I'm going to SSH
into one of the machines.
Oops, that's not going to work.
[INAUDIBLE] SSH into
one of the machines.
All right, and so if
I do psuedo-docker ps,
we can see that there's actually
this engine x web server that's
running that's
serving up the data.
All right, so I'm
going to move this
aside so that you
can actually see.
Because this effect is
actually-- the health
checked restart is quite quick.
And so it's somewhat
difficult to actually see it.
And we may in fact not see it.
I will stop but note what
the Docker container ID is.
I'm going to stop that
container simulating a failure.
You can see that the image
is no longer being served.
But the system, the agent
that's running on this VM,
is going to notice that
that container has stopped.
And it's going to
restart that container.
And now the image is
back and being served.
And if we do that
ps again, you can
see that we have a
new container here.
It's only been up
eight seconds now,
since I killed
the other one that
had been up for three hours.
So that kind of health
checking on the node
means that you
don't have to worry.
You can simply say, I want
this thing to be running.
And the cluster
manager will take
care of ensuring that
it actually is running.
So the next thing that you might
want to do along these lines
is you might want
to actually resize.
I'll move this up again so
there's better visibility.
You may want to actually resize.
Four of Craig is just
a little bit too scary.
And so I'm going
to go over here.
And I can actually say, cloud.
This is the tool.
So it's worth mentioning
Kubernetes has a RESTful HTTP
API.
So you can write
arbitrary clients
that communicate with this
API, create new containers,
create new services, create
replication controllers,
resize replication controllers.
It ships with a
simple command line
tool that allows you
to do these things,
but you're free to build
any kind of orchestration
on top of it.
So I'm going to say, cloud
config resize data cont-- ah,
if I can type-- controller 2.
And so now it's
resized this down.
It's actually killed
two containers there.
They're no longer running
on those machines.
Now I only have two
of these images.
Well, maybe that was
a little bit harsh,
and we actually would prefer
to have three of Craig.
So we will resize
back up to three.
And here now we're going to
see a little bit of a blip
while that container--
killing is fast.
Recreating is slightly
slower, because it's
very easy to stop a process.
Actually starting
the process, getting
engine x ready to serve, takes
a few seconds as you saw.
So now we have three
containers running inside
of Kubernetes all scheduled
onto specific machines.
But again, we don't really care
about that particularly much.
Now, the other
kind of life cycle
that you might want to do,
in addition to resizing,
is actually editing the kind
of thing that you're serving.
So I wanted to give you a little
bit of an illustration of what
work flow does look
like inside of Google,
and workflow might look like
for you out using Kubernetes.
So I have in this directory
the Docker image, the container
that's running on
these machines.
I'm going to open
up the data file.
And Craig-- a little scary.
So we'll replace this with
Brendan, nice, friendly
developer, not product guy.
So at this point, I
can say Docker bill -t
Brendan [INAUDIBLE] data dot.
So this is building
up my Docker image.
I'm going to push
that, push [INAUDIBLE].
OK, one of the nice things
about this decoupling
of the container image
from where the container is
executing is that this
activity of actually updating
my container doesn't actually
change the running service.
So as you see the image
slowly being pushed up,
you won't see any changes
in the running service.
And indeed, even when
the push is completed,
there won't be any changes
in the running service.
I've separated out
application update
from running service update.
So application update
is this atomic thing
that happens with me pushing
a new package somewhere.
Service update becomes
a new atomic thing
that has to do with running that
new container on my cluster.
And by partitioning
them in these ways,
I have much more
reliability in both.
If the application upload
fails, that's fine.
I can redo it.
If the cluster update
fails, it's very easy for me
to roll back to an old version
of the same application.
I don't end up in states
where I'm sort of partially
installed, and it's
impossible to get back,
and I may not even get a clear
signal about whether or not
I succeeded.
All right, so my image
has been updated.
I'm going to go over here.
And I'm going to say--
clear so everyone can see.
I'm going to say, cloud
config.sh rolling update,
let's say, -u 15 seconds
rolling [INAUDIBLE].
And so what this is saying is
I want to do a rolling update.
A rolling update means
one container at a time.
I'll bring it down, bring
it back up with the update.
I'm using an inter-restart
period of 15 seconds--
way, way faster than
I would recommend
anybody doing in production.
But I don't want to have you
sitting around for five minutes
while we restart containers.
So we'll start this off.
And what you're going
to see is as this
runs, that container went down.
It's going to be
starting back up.
I'll go back.
And with luck, as
it starts back up,
there'll be a friendlier
face to be seen.
We'll keep our fingers crossed.
The tension is starting
to kill me here.
It's actually having
to pull the image.
Yay, there I am.
The previous restarts didn't
have to pull the image.
It was already on the machine.
These machines actually have to
pull new data down from Docker.
So there's a little
bit of a second
while we pull the
image off the network.
So that last one should finish
booting up with any luck.
The update is finished
at this point.
And in a few seconds,
the update will complete.
So that's really a demo of
some of the flexibility.
When you stop thinking
about virtual machines,
you start thinking
about containers.
You start thinking about
scheduling containers
and scheduling work out
onto this homogeneous pool
of resources where the machines
really disappear and you start
just thinking in terms of
CPU, memory, and the software
that I want to run.
And you add on top of it
some management concepts
that provide the right kind of
abstractions for both the life
cycle things you do
in your application,
as well as the ways
that make linking pieces
of your application
both decoupled and easy.
You start being able to
build applications the way
that we've built
applications inside of Google
for many, many years.
And so with that, I'll jump
back into the presentation
and hope that I grab
the right clicker.
All right, I wanted to give a
little bit of an example of how
you might build a more
complicated application.
That application was really
just a single container.
Here's an example of a
more complicated guest book
that you can find on
the Kubernetes GitHub.
And in this case, we
have three front ends
controlled by a front end
replica controller talking
to a service that's defined as
a Redis slave service being read
slaves talking to a replicated
set of Redis slaves,
talking to a master
service that lives
on top of a single master.
So this is just an example
of how you might build up
a more complex tier
of applications.
All right, so I
just wanted to end
by saying we've thought
a lot about containers
and how you build and manage
containers and cluster
management systems
over last 10 years.
I'm super excited to launch
this open source project out
to the developers'
community in general,
and being able to take
the step forward together
with everyone else for how
we're going to manage containers
for the next 10 years.
Thanks very much.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
BRENDAN BURNS: Some links.
I wanted to also add as
a gift to every one-- you
may have seen this
already-- you've
got a $500 credit for the
Google Cloud Platform.
Go and use it to build out
your best and brightest ideas.
Thanks.
And I think we have
about 6 and 1/2 minutes
left for questions and answers.
So I'll bring Craig
back up and we can--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRENDAN BURNS: Sorry.
BRENDAN BURNS: All
right, yes, I'll
leave you the important thing.
I don't know, pictures of me
might be worth more than $500?
No, probably not.
That's to bad.
All right, so if there
are any questions
that we can answer-- yes?
AUDIENCE: I would like to
know if you can manage quota
assigned to a container when
you use a container [INAUDIBLE],
I mean if you can assign
some limited memory
or CPU to various containers
you deploy side by side.
BRENDAN BURNS: So
currently, the container
manifest does not
allow you to do that.
But it's an evolving API
and an evolving standard.
And so we will definitely be
building towards doing that.
And you could even send
us the poll request.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's [INAUDIBLE].
And I would like
to know if I can
use Kubernetes in my
own private cloud.
BRENDAN BURNS: Yes, absolutely.
We want to make sure that
it runs really, really
well in the Google
Cloud Platform.
And we have developed it on
the Google Cloud Platform.
So you'll find that that's
the most seamless experience.
But we have both a local
development environment
that will run on your machine,
a single cluster if you will,
a single node
cluster if you will.
And we've also had
people deploy it
onto their own machines as well.
AUDIENCE: And what
virtualization technologies
do you support?
BRENDAN BURNS: Sorry, what?
AUDIENCE: Do you
support VMware, KVM,
what virtualization
technologies?
BRENDAN BURNS: So we actually
do not use virtualization.
If you happen to deploy it
onto a set of virtual machines,
then it will work.
But if you deploy it onto bare
metal, it will work as well.
So the underlying
container technology
is the Docker
container technology.
And there's a number
of different back ends
that could be used
for that container.
Did that help [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Do Kubernetes spin up
virtual machines automatically?
BRENDAN BURNS: The scripts
that we have currently
will spin up machines for
you in Compute Engine.
But there aren't
any scripts that
spin them up for
other platforms.
Again, because it's an
open source project,
we very much welcome
contributions
from other people who want to
be able to make it work on--
CRAIG MCLUCKIE:
And we are working
with the broader community.
You'll see over
the next few weeks,
I think support for other
providers will spring up.
Because the community
demands that.
BRENDAN BURNS:
Right, absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my question is
related to container optimized
VMs versus plain VMs.
So when I actually
spin up a normal JCVM,
nothing stops me from
installing Docker and using
Docker Run to actually launch
a container, versus a container
optimized VM where
I can actually
use a [INAUDIBLE]
file, which is going
to be the metadata for
my Docker container.
So is the difference primarily
in the YAML file acting
as a start up script, or do
you do anything beyond that?
So is it just a convenience
that you provide
to the agent on the
start up script,
or does it have further
optimization within the VM?
BRENDAN BURNS:
Convenience is a big part
it, actually, to
be honest, right?
We definitely want
to make people
think about running
containers not running VMs.
And so if you can simply
start thinking about the thing
that you're running
as being a container,
I think that's a good thing.
And that's a huge thing.
But there's also
a lot of software
that we've installed
onto that VM that
make running a container better.
And that includes
things like cAdviser,
which is a program that some
Google engineers launched
at DockerCon also
about 10 days ago,
which is a way to get really
rich statistics about what's
going on inside
of your container.
That includes agent,
the on board agent
that's responsible
for health checking
and automatic restarting
of the container.
There's nothing
that prevents you
from installing these
things yourself.
And so you could build an analog
of the container optimized
VM manually yourself
if you wanted to.
But we're going to curate
this thing going forward.
And really, we're going to
do our best to make sure
that that VM is the best
experience you can have
for running containers on
the Google Cloud Platform.
AUDIENCE: So without
Kubernetes, the container
optimized VMs are basically
plain vanilla JCVMs with agents
and some extra start up skips?
BRENDAN BURNS: That's correct.
They're really static VMs
without the cluster management
layer on top of them.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: And we'll
produce a nice tuning
experience so that
when you actually want
to just go from the
command line or from the UI
and want to get a
container running,
it'll be a very
slick experience.
AUDIENCE: Final question.
Will Kubernetes show up on
the developer console any day?
BRENDAN BURNS: It's
available on GitHub
right now as something
you can install yourself.
AUDIENCE: No, the
developer console,
the UI to deploy and
manage containers.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE:
So we can't signal
where we're going exactly.
But it would be
reasonable to expect
that we would have a
hosted version of this
in the not too distant future.
It's actually worth mentioning
that what we're really
looking to do here is
to engage the community.
You can tell where we're
going with this stuff, right?
This is the way we've been
running our internal workloads.
And by reaching out
with Kubernetes,
we're putting an API
out for conversation.
Help us shape it to
be the thing you want,
and we'll provide the
fully hosted version of it
that's running in our framework.
That's ultimately where
we want to go with this.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So if I understood
this correctly,
every container speaks
only to other containers
via a service abstraction.
So it has no knowledge of
the other containers running.
And since it is only
talking to a service,
you can scale it out.
Now, my question
is this only works
if the individual containers
talk to other services
but are stateless.
What happens if you
went onto data sharding,
for example, in
which case you would
need to speak to a
specific container
to access a given shard?
So do you have a zoo
keeper like mechanism,
or how do you manage this?
BRENDAN BURNS: Sure.
So just a little bit
of a clarification,
there's nothing that precludes a
container from talking directly
to another container.
And indeed you could
talk to the API
and introspect it and figure
out what containers are running,
or you could hard code some
sort of configuration in.
I think that we think of
service as being convenient ways
to link things together.
But they're definitely
not the exclusive way
to link things together.
I guess the other
thing that I would say
is it's come up
in other contexts
inside of the community
about providing
richer semantics
for that service.
So right now, that service is
a round robin load balancer.
But you could imagine being able
to define a service type that
is a master elected balancer
that only ever takes
your traffic to the current
master, or a sharded.
Sharding becomes trickier.
Because you have to have some
notion of what the sharding
function is, right?
And so that becomes a trickier
concept to put in there.
But you can imagine these
primitives becoming richer
in the future.
Or you could just
simply bake your own.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Sort of building along that,
we built our own similar kind
of concept for deployment
where we tried to abstract away
all of the messiness of what
it was you were running on.
And we started out with
a declarative syntax.
But it rapidly became
clear that if we
wanted to take advantage
of existing software,
they had their own peculiar
workflows and configuration
and everything, for
example like Mongo.
Trying to containerize
Mongo, we ended up
going with an
imperative syntax just
because if you've got multiple
shards with their own master,
their own triplets of
voting rights and things
like that, it gets to be
a fairly complicated dance
to get it set up.
So sort of along the lines
of the previous question,
is there anything
built in for sort
of identifying in
an abstract way?
You kind of had the
idea of roles as labels,
but like sort of having staged
workflows for, OK, everybody
needs to get to this state and
then run this set of stuff,
and then now
everybody's in this.
Oh, and now you've
advertised yourself as ready,
so we can add you to
the load balancer.
Is there anything
along those lines,
or are you heading
in that direction?
BRENDAN BURNS: I
guess I would say
that if we were to build
something like that,
I would like to see it as
something that lived on top
of this API rather
than being something
that existed within this API.
I think that I could imagine
some degree of orchestration
within a pod where you
might say something like,
this is an
initialization container.
Please run this initialization
container to completion
and then start the server.
But I think when
you're starting to talk
about really significant
workflow, that kind of system
is probably better served by
being something that lives
on top of the scheduling
API rather than apart
of the scheduling API.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: I would
completely agree with that.
I think the ideal
here is to provide
a really useful
generic scheduling API,
and then provide a framework
so you can create abstractions
on it.
So you'd be able to identify
something within that,
get a channel to that,
communicate with that, in a way
that makes sense to you.
But that does need to be a
strict abstraction on top
of the system.
That's exactly right.
AUDIENCE: It sounds like
the container optimized
VM has lot of
similarities with CoreOS.
And they strive to be
in an ideal environment
for containers to run.
Can you speak to some of the
differences between those two
projects, or advantages
and disadvantages?
BRENDAN BURNS: I
think philosophically,
they're definitely very similar.
They're machine images that are
optimized to run containers.
I think there's some
stuff like cAdviser that
isn't present on
CoreOS right now.
Maybe it will be.
And again, I think that
this is a place where
one of the reasons
for getting out there
into the community with
an open version of this
is to really engage with
those sorts of people
and see if there's a consensus
around what the node image
should be, see if there's
a consensus around what
the declarative syntax or
scheduling tasks should be.
And if we reach a place where
there's a POSIX standard
or whatever that happens
to be for what a container
machine looks like, I think
that's a great place to get to.
AUDIENCE: So you would
see a convergence.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Let me just
sort of step back a little bit.
I completely agree with Brendan.
But the thing about
what we're doing here
is a pattern that
we want to engage
the community around
a conversation on.
So we will offer up a
container optimized VM.
We fully expect a lot
of other providers
to provide the self same.
You could expect the regular
person to come up with that.
We want to engage the
open source community
in a conversation around what
the right set of abstractions,
what the right set
of interfaces, are.
And we want to make sure we're
open and not opinionated.
So we love the guys from CoreOS.
We love the guys from Docker.
We're spending a
lot of time working
to bring our expertise
to operationalize it.
And what we're hoping
to do with Kubernetes,
and with the container VMs,
is to start the dialogue
and figure out what's great.
Maybe they'll take
some of our patterns.
Maybe we'll take some of theirs.
But it's just a
great starting point.
BRENDAN BURNS: I
guess I would also
say that I think
that CoreOS is--
and I'll let people finish.
But CoreOS also basically uses
systemd as their abstraction
layer on their machines.
And so it's less container
introspectable at some level.
You can't really walk
up to a CoreOS machine
and say, what are the Docker
containers that you're running?
You say, what are
the systemd units,
and then extract from
the command line,
oh, here's the Docker
things that I'm running.
I think we wanted to take
a more declarative approach
to the introspection
as well and really
be able to ask for concrete
information from the machine.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: And
whenever we can,
if you look at
the way we're sort
of engaging this
community, we're
getting really
strongly behind things
like [INAUDIBLE] container.
And we're actually putting a
tremendous amount of effort
into it.
Because we think it's
the right abstraction.
With something
like Kubernetes, we
want to create an
abstraction that we
think is the best possible
abstraction out there.
And a lot of it's based on a
decade of experience running
containers.
So we don't do this lightly.
And we want to absolutely
engage the community
and have the conversation around
what's right for the community.
BRENDAN BURNS: I think
we are out of time.
But we'll take-- you
have a quick question?
Then absolutely we'll
have people come up.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: And
we'll be around.
AUDIENCE: How does
Kubernetes scale?
Is there a Kubernetes
of Kubernetes?
If there are more
than one Kubernetes,
how do they share
the information
or the status of what
they are handling?
BRENDAN BURNS: So right
now the way that it works,
the premise is, you give us a
set of resources-- 50 VMs, five
VMs, whatever it happens
to be-- and we'll
manage work on top
of those machines.
So in some sense, you have to
have some sense of the resource
usage you may need.
But it's also the case
that you could turn up
two separate clusters that
would be essentially completely
unaware of each other, right?
They are hermetically sealed
clusters in and of themselves.
And so if you ran
out of resources,
you could turn up another.
Although we would anticipate
that what you might actually
want to do is tear
down your old cluster
and turn up a larger cluster and
migrate your containers across.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: And
one thing I'd say
is when we designed Kubernetes,
the intent was to produce.
And there was simple, lean,
and extensible, right?
We wanted to use it as a segue
to have a broader conversation.
So a lot of the things
you might expect
in terms of very high
levels of scalability,
very high levels of
redundancy, are not yet
present in that offering.
We absolutely expect
the community and us
to work towards that.
But whenever possible, we
favored understandability
and simplicity over this
very complex system.
Because we wanted to
have the dialogue.
And frankly, for a
lot of customers,
where they are today, than
have relatively humble needs.
And having something
that's extremely accessible
is a very good thing.
And that's how we designed
it from the start.
BRENDAN BURNS: Cool.
Well, I think we are completed.
But please come up and
talk to us afterwards.
And we'll be around
at the conference.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE:
Thank you so much.
BRENDAN BURNS: Have a good time.
Thank you.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]